non non a réussi à passer
les six jolies la place de leader et
chanteur
du folk bâtard de la musique des
antipodes c'est leur propre définition
sages comme des sauvages c'est une
musique cosmopolite involontaire on
n'est pas contre on est content de faire
ça mais ça s'est fait vraiment par
hasard mais comme nos vies qu enfin moi
je ma mère est américaine et mon père
est français et j'ai grandi en grèce
donc déjà sa c3 identité que j'ai pas
choisi c'est comme ça et puis ils se
mêlent c'est un peu pareil ça s'est
baladé par tous on récolte un peu ce qui
nous plaît on ne mélange à nous
les identités diverses du bouzouki
grecque au cavaquinho brésilien de leurs
influences éclectiques qu'ils écrivent
et composent au gré de leurs rencontres
et de leurs voyages
ajustements
ce soir on est en voiture est alors on a
trouvé une bassoniste en covoiturage ça
ça va mais moi j'ai trouvé un mexicain à
bruxelles qui joue tout plein
d'instruments bizarres voilà presque
pareil tu t'entends bien tu fais de la
musique voici ça marche y a pas on
essaie de ne pas se dire tiens il
faudrait qu'on ait une basse une
batterie une guitare et un clavier pour
faire un truc
[Musique]
des mélodies métissé pour un voyage
autour du monde avec une escale vendredi
dernier à la batterie de guyancourt
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il me
[Musique]
ma main